wenn man ihn zeichnet muss man
eigentlich nur die haare glaube ich mal
und jeder weiß um wen es geht donald
trump und seine frisur sind noch mal ein
ganz eigenes thema die witzigsten
frisuren denn wir sehen wir wollen uns
gleich einmal den fünften platz
anschauen
auf jeden fall seine sie können nicht
weggehen aber vielleicht wissen jetzt
die männer in ihrem raum besser kann ein
da hatte ich trotzdem was machen wie
echte müssen die sein nur weil sie jetzt
im wind nicht weglegen wir können noch
nicht mitreden ich eigentlich auch nicht
ich habe da gibst du diese möglichkeit
unsere technisch prüfen wie man sich
morgens ins haar gerd schröder war immer
experte ging es aber um andere dinge
glaube ich da ging es ja um die frage
wer habe ich noch ein bisschen
und dann gibt's dieses muss nicht
gefärbt sind sie ja noch dazu muss man
ja auch sehr viele mythen um so zum
beispiel das ist eine familie sowie
lieder war wir mitglieder seine haare
färben und deswegen seien die auch immer
so unterschiedlich war wenn man genau
darauf achtet dann haben die oben immer
ein bisschen eine andere farbe als unten
und es gibt diesen mythos dass er sie
von den familienmitgliedern färben lässt
schön kann sich deswegen so
unterschiedliche töne haben sich jürgen
überhaupt noch sogar so voll ist
wir reden im moment auch da muss man
sagen es gibt auch das gerücht dass er
sich mal für 60.000 dollar die haare hat
verlängern lassen
also ich würde sagen um die haare von
donald trump gibt es ranken sich so
viele mythen wie eva um hexen häuser da
gibt es wirklich sehr viele spannende
effekt zum beispiel ist es ja auch oft
die rede davon gewesen dass er ein
toupet trägt wir bevor wir darüber
hier ist ja dort große ding sind das
wirklich sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja die naja ziel uns nichts vor
das war bei einer wahlkampfveranstaltung
vor einigen jahren bevor er das erste
mal präsident geworden ist vielleicht
bleibt das auch einmal aber auf jeden
fall ist schon ein paar jahre her und
anlass war eigentlich ein artikel in der
new york times
da hat ihn nämlich jemand als dem toupet
mann bezeichnet und er hat diesen
artikel genommen hat den laut vorgelesen
und hat gesagt guck mal leute hier meine
haare sind echt und es war nicht nur die
einzige veranstaltung der hat das visum
comedy programm hat er das immer mit auf
seine tour genommen und hat das jedes
mal wieder erzählt und hat jedes mal
wieder aus dem publikum mit jemandem
geholt der dann in seine haare fassen
durfte als beweis dafür dass er kein
toupet trägt ich glaube mittlerweile ich
habe mich im vorfeld mal ein bisschen
recherchiert ich glaube mittlerweile
auch nicht dass er ein toupet training
nicht aber die haare sind wanka wenn ich
lache und erzählt ja immer dass er seine
haare mit head and shoulders wäscht also
ein drogerie produkt sozusagen sehr
bodenständig und dann würde er sie luft
trocknen lassen und während er die luft
trocknen lässt ließ da eine zeitung und
dann wird das eigentlich kamen und dann
nimmt den kampf und dann kämpfte sie zur
seite und dann benutzt er sehr viel hass
aber ich möchte einmal sagen die sind ja
im 21 jahrhundert
wenn wir uns über die frisur einer
politikerin so und erhalten würden wir
über die frisur eines mannes eines
politikers da würde jeder sagen oh ist
das frauenfeindlich darüber gestellt
wurde ja schon getan aber jetzt über
welche frauen über welche frau wird so
gerät tatsächlich muss ich daran kann
niemand würde so jemand der so über
frauen redet muss sich dann vielleicht
auch nicht von der nur als heitere von
anfang
kann sein genauso dann damit rechnen
dass auch wirklich genau hin und jemand
der das sonderprogramm mit aufnimmt und
quasi ich meine die er den ersten clip
dem wir den haben der war bei einer
corona pressekonferenz niemand hat ihm
nach seinen hahn gefragt er das einfach
an sich aus gesagt habe machen wird zum
in die hier
es gibt ernstere themen wichtigere
themen moment großartig assistiert hier
kommt momenten übertreibt es um die
stürmische frisur von donald trump geht
und zwar ist das natürlich immer ein
problem wir kennen das alle in der nähe
von flugzeugen wird es windig und hier
will er natürlich gleich in die air
force one sein flieger steigen und dann
muss man den witz einfach machen das
ganze wird zur herford denn wir sehen da
hilft auch das ganze hass predigt dass
janina gerade angesprochen hat da sitzt
genau nichts mehr
und jetzt sehen wir nämlich auch was für
unterschiedliche haben dort ja hat sich
meine unschuld zu sehen sind
das gibt's ja also das kind ja was kennt
ja jeder so sich aus wenn ich aussteige
aber ich kann das sagen es ist so und
donald trump spielt ja viel golf und
wenn dann noch ein bisschen salzwasser
im haar ist und die sonne dann einmal
von süden scheint von westen und von
osten man muss ja mal haben sich das
einfach ein bisschen irgendwas muss ja
gemacht werden weil in den
steuererklärungen die wir dann auch
gesehen haben und den ganz kanada hieß
dann aber es gibt auch 70.000 dollar für
die haare also irgendwo aber ich habe
wirklich sehr amerikanische präsident
das absichtlich macht also oben bisschen
mehr gold an den seiten ein bisschen
mehr weiß hinten vielleicht ein bisschen
schwarz also vielleicht hat ja heimlich
aber ich glaube dass ich gerade nicht
für besondere alten karte ehrlich das
riecht ja ja der mann gestimmt eine
haare eigentlich egal den gibt es um
andere das würde ich so nicht sagen dass
wir natürlich gleich auch noch in den
nächsten punkt schon es geht weiter um
die haare
es ist noch weit bevor er präsident
geworden ist aber die frisur war
dieselbe und er ist ein die sehr gern
gesehener gast bei wrestlemania und den
mann den wir gerade sehen der
veranstalter der ganze sache die wir
waren immer in so einem spaß clinch ja
und dann musste einer 3 es waren nicht
die haare von donald trump aber also wie
viel spaß hat er bitte gerade bei der
ganzen sache er hat also seinen
kontrahenten die haare komplett
abrasieren also ich muss sagen als ich
die bilder das erste mal gesehen habe da
hatte ich wahnsinnig mitleid mit vince
mcmahon das ist ja der veranstalter dem
da die haare rasiert wurden
der hat ja man hat das jetzt nicht so
genau gehört aber der fleht wirklich na
also ich wir wissen auch alle wrestling
ist große show aber ich weiß nicht also
trampert wirklich mit einem genuss diese
haare abrasiert und ich weiß nicht wie
er reagiert hätte wenn er quasi mit
glatze verpasst bekommen hätte viel
interessanter wäre aber gewesen die
szene vorher zu zeigen wer da haut trump
einem von den rest an eins auf die
fresse und steigt im kampf mit ein aber
das noch mal wieder nach haben sie super
drum schlecht wären wir nur in der us
presse mit
hast du noch keiner was aus seiner
politischen karriere war 13 jahre ist
das glaube ich ja bald schon im
wahlkampf für irgendwas im wahlkampf
2016 war es trotzdem auch das eine große
thema die haare und da war ja noch mit
vielen der entertainment branche ganz
gut so gut dass einer ihm sogar dann
einmal da richtig kräftig durchpusten
ruft
[Applaus]
daher ist
[Musik]
da sieht man wie wenig haar das
eigentlich ist das ist einfach nur
wahnsinnig lang aber ich bewundere jimmy
fallon dafür dass er sich das getraut
hat wo sich sagen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren